[Music]
your grandfather is a selfish old prick
who resents taking care of his family
and yet you all end up back here at my
house welcome i'm your only uncle so
most of your favorite outfit right
sounds like something
[Music]
i have no idea how you are going to law
school so you can sue your father for
child support no so he can help with
your fines about the septic tank
[Music]
[Music]
okay two rules
i'm never gonna let you win
[Applause]
i'll take care of you teach the male
sciences i saw you in the yard playing
sports you're not very good find some
other activities i like to read you read
enough of those maybe
you could become a writer one more thing
very important never hit a woman
even if she stabs you with scissors
got it see me and cool down by the
school
today my nephew is officially a man
[Applause]
it is a great pleasure to offer you a
place in the yale class of 1986.
hey i'm jr sydney you're in my class
i doubt it
so what do you want to be j.r i'm going
to be a writer
what's your main theme the absent father
poor boy wants a rich girl
she doesn't love you
what you do next is going to be
important
would you go and stare up at the
building in the rain
[Applause]
[Music]
in life you gotta have it
if you don't have it
you never get it
and i say you got it
[Music]
you